When I was a kid,
the violin was the center of my life.
I'd run home from the bus stop
after school and practice for hours.
Every Saturday, my mom and I
would wake up at four in the morning
to catch a train to New York
so I could study at Juliard.
Here's a throwback to eight-year-old me
performing the violin.
Some questionable fashion choices
from young Maya here,
not going to lie.
But anyway, when I was a teenager,
my musical idol, Itzhak Perlman,
invited me to be his private student.
And my big dream of becoming
a concert violinist felt within reach.
But then one morning when I was 15,
I was practicing this tricky
technical passage.
I struggled to get it right,
and I overextended my finger
on a single note.
I heard a popping sound.
I’d permanently damaged
the tendons in my hand,
and my dream was over.
I share this story
because unexpected change
happens to all of us.
An accident or an illness,
a relationship that suddenly ends.
Today, I'm not a violinist,
but I'm a cognitive scientist.
And I'm interested in how we respond
to exactly this kind of change.
I spent the past two decades
studying the science of human behavior.
And today I host a podcast called
"A Slight Change of Plans" --
(Audience cheers)
glad you guys like it --
where I interview people
from all over the world
about their life-altering experiences.
I started this podcast because change
is scary for a lot of us, am I right?
For one, it is filled with uncertainty,
and we hate uncertainty.
Research shows that we're more stressed
when we're told we have a 50 percent
chance of getting an electric shock
than when we're told we have
a 100 percent chance.
It's wild, right?
I mean, we'd rather be sure
that a bad thing is going to happen
than to have to deal with any uncertainty.
Change is also scary
because it involves loss of some kind.
By definition, we're departing
from an old way of being
and entering a new one.
And when we experience a change
that we wouldn't
have chosen for ourselves,
it's easy to feel
that our lives are contracting,
that were more limited than before.
But when we take this perspective,
we fail to account for an important fact.
That when an unexpected
change happens to us,
it can also inspire
lasting change within us.
We become different people
on the other side of change.
What we're capable of, what we value
and how we define ourselves,
these things can all shift.
And if we can learn to pay close attention
to these internal shifts,
we may just find that rather
than limiting us,
change can actually expand us.
Alright, today I'm going to share with you
three questions you can ask yourself
the next time life throws you
that dreaded curveball.
In the moment, I know it's so easy
to focus on what you've lost.
And so I'm really hoping that you can use
these questions as tools
to discover all that you might gain.
Alright, let’s start
with question number one.
This is inspired by a conversation
I had on my podcast
with a woman named Christine Ha,
and it's about our capabilities.
Christine was 24 when a rare autoimmune
disease left her permanently blind.
At the time, she was learning to cook
the Vietnamese dishes
that she had loved in childhood.
But now cooking even simple
meals was tough.
She told me that her
frustration peaked one day
when she was making
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich.
She struggled to align
the two slices of bread
and sticky jelly dripped all over
her hands and onto the counter.
She threw the sandwich into the trash,
and she felt really defeated
by the limited future
that she imagined for herself.
Since Christine lived alone though,
she had no choice but to keep at it.
She remembers her delight
when she successfully cut an orange
for the first time
and when she scrambled an egg
without burning it.
As she spent more hours in the kitchen,
she realized that cooking was far more
multi-sensory than she had thought.
While she couldn't see
if the garlic had browned,
she could rely on the smell
and the sizzling sounds in the pan.
But Christine also realized
something bigger.
Something new was emerging within her.
At the start of her vision loss
she had cooked just to get by.
I mean, it was really
just a practical thing.
But now she was thrilled
by the challenge of it all.
She tackled harder and harder
recipes over the years
and eventually became
the first-ever blind contestant
on the TV show "Master Chef."
And guess what?
She won the entire damn thing.
(Laughs)
Christine's a rock star.
She's an amazing, amazing person.
This brings us to the first question
that you can ask yourself
the next time you face
something unexpected.
"How might this change
change what you're capable of?"
When we predict how we'll respond
to any given change,
we tend to imagine what our present-day
selves will be like in that new situation.
Research by the psychologist Dan Gilbert
shows that we greatly underestimate
how much we'll change in the future,
even though we fully acknowledge
we've changed considerably in the past.
Our psychology continually
tricks us into believing
that who we are, right now,
in this very moment,
is the person that's here to stay.
But the person meeting the challenges
after an unexpected change
will be different.
You will be different.
Today, Christine is a world-renowned chef.
She goes by the nickname The Blind Cook,
and she owns three restaurants in Texas.
And importantly,
she's really curious about what else
she can achieve without vision.
These days, you can find her
snowboarding and rock climbing
on the weekends.
Christine shared with me something
that she could never have imagined
thinking before all this.
That if given the choice today,
she would choose not to have
her vision restored.
Though she did tell me
she'd like it back for a moment
because she really wants to know
what Justin Bieber looks like.
(Laughter)
Alright, let's move on
to the second question.
This one is about our values,
and it's inspired by a conversation I had
with a science journalist
named Florence Williams.
One evening about five years ago,
Florence and her husband were hosting
a dinner party for their friends.
As she was preparing the salad,
her husband handed her his phone
so that she could read
an email from a relative.
But he'd mistakenly
pulled up the wrong email.
What Florence saw instead
was a lengthy note from her husband,
confessing his love to another woman.
I know.
Florence’s 25-year marriage
came to an end,
and she told me that she was taken aback
by the physical and emotional
intensity of her heartbreak.
She said it felt like she'd been plugged
into a faulty electrical socket.
Since Florence is a problem
solver by nature,
she instinctively saw her heartbreak
as a problem to solve
and develop a year-long,
systematic plan to try and fix it.
Florence tried a bunch of things.
She took solo trips into the wilderness,
she tried a range
of experimental therapies,
She even went to the Museum
of Broken Relationships,
which I promise is the thing.
You name it, she tried it.
But by the end of the year,
none of these remedies
had healed her broken heart.
And so Florence had no choice
but to entertain
a new philosophy altogether.
Maybe a broken heart
was not a problem to solve.
And maybe closure wasn't the answer.
Research by the psychologist
Dacher Keltner shows
that when we reduce our need
for what's called cognitive closure,
the desire to arrive at clear
and definitive answers,
our capacity to feel joy
and beauty expands.
Florence told me that when she freed
herself from this goal-oriented mindset,
a mindset, by the way,
that she had valued
for so much of her life
up until this point,
she began to find unexpected
delight in the unknown.
This leads us to the second question
you can ask yourself
the next time you face
something unexpected.
How might this change
change what you value?
The unexpected implosion
of Florence's marriage
has permanently shifted the way
that she sees her life.
From a puzzle in need of solutions
to a more serendipitous path of discovery.
Now, when Florence goes hiking,
she's just as likely to sit still,
feeling the breeze,
as she is to try and make the summit.
She no longer makes five-year plans.
And she's comfortable not knowing
all the answers around her heartbreak.
By the way, I was texting
with Florence the other day,
and she's currently in a very
happy relationship.
If her ex-husband is listening to this,
I just want him to know
she's doing great, buddy.
(Laughter)
Alright, now on to question number three.
This one is about how we define ourselves.
It's about our self-identities.
And it comes from my personal story
of change with the violin.
When my injury took
the violin away from me,
I found myself grieving
not just the loss of the instrument,
but also the loss of myself.
For so long, the violin had defined me,
that without it, I wasn't sure
who I was or who I could be.
I felt stuck.
I'd later learned that this phenomenon
is known as identity paralysis.
It happens to a lot of us
when we face the unexpected.
Who we think we are and what we're about
is suddenly called into question.
But I since realized
that there was something different,
something more stable that I could
have anchored my identity to.
And this brings us to that third
and final question.
How might this change
change how you define yourself?
When I re-examine
my relationship with the violin,
I discovered that what I really missed
wasn't the instrument itself,
but the fact that music
had given me a vehicle
for connecting emotionally with others.
I remember as a little kid
playing for people
and feeling kind of awestruck
that we might all feel
something new together.
What this means for me today
is that I no longer anchor
my identity to specific pursuits
like being a violinist
or a cognitive scientist
or a podcaster.
Instead, I anchor my identity
to what lights me up about those pursuits,
what really energizes me.
And for me, it's a love
of human connection and understanding.
I now define myself not by what I do,
but why I do it.
Look, unexpected change comes for us all,
whether we like it or not.
And when it does, it can really suck.
But I'm hoping that if we can stay open
to how we might internally change,
how we might expand,
it can help us weather the storm.
Life recently threw me
a new slight change of plans.
I've always wanted to be a mom,
but becoming one has been difficult
and my husband and I
have had to navigate pregnancy losses
and other heartbreaks over the years.
And now I'm not sure what will happen.
But I'm using these three questions
to help me during this tough time.
I'm asking myself
how this unexpected challenge
might change what I'm capable of,
what I value, and how I define myself.
I'm still figuring things out.
But what I can tell you right now
is that I'm imagining a future me
who is expanding her definition
of what it means to parent.
Who's perhaps finding what she craved
from motherhood in other places.
At a minimum,
this exploration has allowed me
to loosen my grip on the identity
of Mom just a bit.
And I found it freeing.
I'm beginning to see change
with more possibility.
And I'm hoping you can, too.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)